how does battlefield fives offering to
the Battle Royale genre hold up well I
got some hands-on with firestorm so I've
invited fellow battle royale fanatic
willpotter in to find out more about it
bill hello yes I'm excited to hear what
you think because I know you're a big
battlefield fan mm-hmm played all of the
battle rails yep so yeah right off the
bat I mean I couldn't picture what a
battlefield battle rail is like but what
is it actually like to play it's stuck
thankfully very close to the core
battlefield values and it feels very
much like battlefield 5 thankfully so if
you've played but already it will be
nice and easy to pick up it's kept like
the core tenets of squad play in mind
it's got like this suite of vehicles
that you'd expect vehicles are really
like one of the defining things about
this battle royale in in particular each
barrel kind of has its own stick
vehicles seem to play a big part in the
firestorm in particular that's quite a
few of them on there yeah there's like
17 Wow and you get anything from
tractors that can tow along 80 guns or
AAA guns there's a gyrocopter
there's half-tracks sports cars and
fibia Svea khals but you kind of went in
expecting the vehicles to be quite
imbalanced because I mean if you've got
a tank you've got a tank yeah I'll be
around the bushes that's that's a big up
but the thing is is that tanks will now
need fuel it will now need ammo they
can't be repaired and the balance comes
from if you're if you're one person and
you've got a tank great but the thing is
you can't shoot and move at the same
time you need infantry support otherwise
people are going to be able to run
around you and there's a lot of like
panzerfausts and 80 guns in the map that
makes it quite easy to take down and
obviously battle rail has a big emphasis
on sound if you're in a tiger people
gonna hear you coming and obviously like
getting in a tank and trying to hole up
until the end of the game you know is
this gonna be a matter do you think
that's going to come into a firestorm or
just ink the vehicles are going to be
what set this aside from other battle
rail games from my experience they
seemed very powerful when your squad was
at full strength and in the early game
but the map seems to be made in such a
way that there's going to be areas that
vehicles aren't that great like they'll
either be mountainous areas that have
trouble moving across or it'll be open
plains where it's quite easy to get a
Panzerfaust shot off so it is very
useful in early game or fighting other
vehicles but by the time I got into like
the last circle as a few squads left I
opted to ditch them because I wanted to
be stealthy I wanted a surprise attack
and I didn't fancy being a massive
moving target for panzerfausts tell me
tell me about the firestorm itself
because I was watching some of your
gameplay and it looks like quite a
destructive force that's that's chasing
you across the map yeah the firestorm
itself is one of the another one of the
most interesting aspects for firestorm
so talking about the map briefly the map
is is giant it's like the biggest battle
format we're ever seen it's ten times
bigger than Hamada which was already a
massive battlefield 5 map but what's
interesting is that the firestorm is
there from the very beginning it's not
like pub G or fortnight where you land
and then you you see where the circles
coming in as comes from the edges of the
map in one game of firestorm you're not
going to see the whole map the firestorm
existing when you arrive kind of forces
you in different areas so it's time so
you're not going to be able to land at
the same place every time because it
just simply won't be accessible because
the fires already there it is a hugely
destructive force if it goes through
buildings it completely crushes them it
works same same way as any other kind of
ring in about a reality does damage to
you over time but it means that you
can't hide out in the ring and ambush
people your buildings that you're gonna
be enough completely flattened I was
talking to one of the developers and
they've made a conscious thought about
you know in in a lot of battles people
will wait in the safety of the circle
and shoot out into it because they know
that people have to push in they've
designed the circle the firestorm such a
way where it's camping that circle isn't
really viable anymore Yuri have to get
out of it and and more on the map there
are Supply Drop points the so how do
those work and there's supply so they're
like the two big things we'll talk about
them together is the supply drops and
the vehicle break out
they're pretty team focused objectives
and it plays into that risk reward so
supply drops work like capture points in
battlefield when you fill an up and
completely captured a Supply Drop will
come down the thing is there's like a
big balloon overhead and there's alarms
sounding and people can see on the hood
that that is being captured so it's
again that risk reward you have to
defend this objective
that's alerting people to get those
better guns similarly the vehicle
breakouts exists as bunkers in the map
there's two wheels to open up these
massive bunkers and inside will be a
vehicle a safe with some loot and a
weapon box but when you're opening them
a huge alarm is sounding which obviously
alerts people to a presence anywhere up
to two players are immobilized because
they're actually turning these wheels to
get the doors open so it's quite easy to
get ambushed but if you manage to you
know make it through you could get you
know a decent tank out of it or some
pretty sick loot everything you've said
so far sounds like there really is a
focus on team play and I guess that
lends itself to you know what
battlefield players will be used to do
you think people coming from other
battle royale games are gonna have a bit
of a shock to the system trying to play
like that because I know a lot of people
like to be the lone wolf they like to do
their own thing but this seems like you
have to play as a team yeah it's it's
very team centric which I like that was
my favorite thing about battlefield 5
and I play a lot of bot rails as a team
but whereas there is there is a squad
mode and a single solo mode in
battlefield
I felt the solo mode was lacking and the
squad mode for me was really where the
the mode shined because it opened
opportunities to flank and suppress and
use those vehicles and solimões I can't
imagine many people are gonna be using a
tank that they can't shoot and drive
with it just I think going forward if
you're going to play this mode I think
squad play is going to be where it's at
we're talking 64 players 64 players all
in four squads and so considering the
size of the firestorm you get into
action pretty quick it is very much like
get down find some decent loot get into
combat rinse repeat
it's it was it was nicely fast-paced and
what is the loot like exactly I mean
we're expecting you know World War 2 era
weapons yeah it's got similar weapons
from the the core battlefield 5 it
hasn't got all the weapons it seems from
my experience to have four or five from
kind of each category so for example
there's a Tier one Thompson submachine
gun that'll just be the core Thompson 20
rounds no attachments if you find it
Tier three they might have a fifty round
drum it might be more accurate from the
hip it'll have a scope on it so as you
go up the weapon rankings it'll be the
same weapon but you know with additional
perks with additional attachments it'll
just be a little bit better and you can
carry two main weapons and what was
interesting is that there's a downed
mechanic so if you have a pistol and you
are down you can still shoot your pistol
enemies it'll be super hard to aim but
it means you can still be a nuisance and
you can still potentially take someone
out if they're not paying attention and
you know obviously I'm in my head
comparing this to apex Legends which is
you know one of the big battle royale
games at the moment do you think it's
taken any inspiration from that like
does it have ping giggling for example
it has like similar the contextual
marking that it did in again the
battlefield 5 multiplayer so there is
it's not as fleshed out as apex I know
that's the kind of the the thing that
it's going to be compared to the most
because it is the new hotness I think
there is an opportunity there to add
things like weapon pinging and I
experimented with that but when I pinged
a weapon
my teammates said they weren't able to
see it so I think that dude does need to
be built upon again I was seeing an
early build too that could by the time
it releases be changed but considering
there is such an emphasis on teamwork I
do think there needs to be a little more
attention paid to how you communicate
with that team if you don't have a
microphone for example so outside of the
weapons that we talked about what other
things are you looting for and you can
pick up and play with the armor system
works on plates and you can find armor
plates you start with an empty armor
vests find a plate slaughter in gives
you a little more health a little more
survivability medkit system where it has
a cool down so you can't spam med kits
there's reinforcements things like flare
guns flare guns depending on the tier
that they are can be used to spot
enemies they can
to pull in a vehicle they can be used to
call in artillery or call in a v1 rocket
you can have things like mines
panzerschreck dynamite syringes that
allow you to really quickly revive your
teammates there is a lot of thought that
seems to be put in to like your suite of
tools and grenades as you're looting you
you're thinking about the kit the all
that you're building do you want a
submachine gun to get up close do you
want a sniper rifle to tank kind of take
those long shots but then you know that
potentially that's not well if you get
the endgame might not be so useful it's
it's like you're balancing yourself as
the game develops you did have to think
about what your loadout was which I
really liked I think that is really
gonna play into the stories you can talk
about after playing this game and how
you had to change your strategy the
things you have to do in the map and I
think it all fits into that setting do
you think that this is going to be a big
hit with battlefield players I certainly
hope so it is different but it's not so
different that it's kind of alienating
to old players and not off-putting to
new players as a huge battlefield fan as
someone who plays a lot of our games I
really liked the kind of niche that
firestorm is occupying right now I
really do hope it as well that all
sounds awesome and I can't wait to play
it it's coming out very soon
March 25th yep and we can see some of
your winning gameplay yeah GameSpot com
I did manage to eke out a win so that
gameplay will be up right now and if
anyone else has any burning questions
pun very much intended about firestorm
you can feel free to hit me up on
twitter at a regular dave and i'm on
there at the quiff is dead for anything
else baori all related or battle feel
related make sure you stay tuned to
Gamescom oh yeah
thank you hi can you guys get ranking we
go I think that rocks yeah yeah nicely
done there nice this is done team